it's like I'm dating my best friend now
like we do everything together Alana
Thompson watched on as her boyfriend got
arrested for driving Under the Influence
it's never like quiet when we're around
the Here Comes Honey Boo Boo star was in
the car with dreland Carswell when he
was pulled over on Tuesday in Georgia
and taken into custody on five counts
E.T has reached out to the reality stars
rep for Comet you got your driver's
license yes no drug history
are you like trustworthy yes ma'am what
do you enjoy about you know being with
him I mean he drives you everywhere too
yeah he said that he does
dreland spent two days in jail later
released on a 25 000 Bond those other
charges speeding following Too Close
failure to maintain Lane and eluding a
police officer the couple has been
dating for over two years Alana is 17
dreland 21. we've been talking like
every day so we officially decided to
make it official in our relationship the
two most things like everybody is always
talking about is our age Gap and
definitely because like he's black and
I'm white if we're interracial couple
then like really I don't care because
like at the end of the day my sister
approves his mom approves and we're
happy so like what fans gotta say or
what haters gotta say I don't really
care their romance is part of the
family's latest reality series Mama June
Road to Redemption no I can just hire a
tutor right this cute
I really only watch it because Jalen
wants to watch it because he's in it now
another major storyline the family's up
and down relationship with Mama June I
know a lot when I see one
my mom is a liar Alana was in her
mother's wedding last month it's unclear
if dreland was part of the big day have
you met her boyfriend what do you think
yeah I've met Dryland
um yes and they've been together
um over a year
um but so um he's good
um you know he needs to hold down a job
a little bit more but hey that's typical
teenager also if they last fine if they
don't it can be her first love
laughs